[Musique]
à son arrivée à la réunion sébastien
lecornu ministres des autres maires a
enduit en hommage au monument aux morts
à saint denis
en ce jour de rentrée scolaire le
ministre s'est ensuite rendu au port au
collège en le toullec où il a rencontré
des élèves de 6e
un établissement classé en zone
d'éducation prioritaire en force et
innovant pour ces dispositifs
d'inclusion ici une trentaine d'élèves
de segpa les sections d'enseignement
général et professionnel adapté est
directement intégré dans les classes
ordinaires
un modèle qui réussit à ces jeunes en
difficulté d'apprentissage
c'est un modèle national pour la réunion
mais pour l'ensemble de la france
ce qui est accompli ici avec de vraies
victoires victoire individuelle mais qui
font aussi des victoires de génération
toute entière de jeunes gens qui
peut-être parfois par l'égalité des
chances qu'il pourrait peut-être manqué
font justement l'objet de cette
attention et de cette fraternité
particulière qui permet justement de le
ministre a rappelé l'importance des
gestes barrières et le port du masque le
département s'engage en ce sens avec la
mise à disposition de masques de
protection individuelle à l'ensemble de
ses agents eh bien nous mettons à
disposition de nos personnels ces
masques tissus et bien sûr le
département est vigilant pour faire en
sorte que chaque religion puisse
disposer de son masque aujourd'hui donc
nous travaillons avec les services du
rectorat
si c'est nécessaire le département fera
les efforts qui s'imposent pour
accompagner et bien chaque collège
chaque collégien dans les efforts
d'équipement pour favoriser l'égalité et
l'inclusion du plus grand nombre d
élèves à l'enseignement
le président du département annoncé la
continuité du dispositif du plan
tablettes numériques
après avoir mis à disposition quatre
mille tablettes durant le confinement la
collectivité prévoit de doter chaque
établissement de niveau secondaire de 80
tablettes
[Musique]